la nefasta labor obstruccionista de la
mayoría de congresistas
identificados con intereses racistas y
sociales En general Ha logrado crear el
caos con el fin de asumir el gobierno al
margen de la voluntad popular y del
orden constitucional a lo largo de una
misma mañana en un vertiginoso periodo
de unas tres horas Perú vivió un intento
de golpe de estado la detención de un
presidente y la jura de una sucesora con
la que se restablecía el orden
constitucional sin embargo toda esta
historia va mucho más allá de Pedro
Castillo porque en realidad Esta es la
historia del declive político del Perú
una historia de odio confrontación
deslealtad y ambición de poder
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué empujó al ya expresidente Pedro
Castillo a llevar a cabo semejante acto
de subversión institucional realmente
era competente para disolver el congreso
Por qué fracasó este intento y quizás la
pregunta más importante de todas qué
demonios está pasando con la política
peruana que va de mal en peor es
Castillo el único culpable queridos
amigos amigas En este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
lo primero de todo es situarnos Pedro
Castillo un humilde maestro de escuela
rural de una de las zonas más pobres del
Perú Con un fuerte discurso
antiestablishment y ninguna experiencia
política o de gestión fue investido
presidente el 28 de julio del 2021 esta
vez Un gobierno del pueblo ha llegado
para gobernar con el pueblo y para el
pueblo es la primera vez que nuestro
país
será gobernado por un campesino una
persona que pertenece como mucho de los
peruanos a los sectores oprimidos por
tantos siglos sin embargo apenas ocupó
la presidencia durante
495 días completos esto es menos de año
y medio
[Música]
en las elecciones presidenciales del
2021 Castillo pasó a la segunda vuelta
con apenas el
18,9% de los votos y consiguió hacerse
con la victoria por la mínima Por poco
más de 40.000 de los casi 19 millones de
votos emitidos ganó gracias a
enfrentarse en segunda vuelta a keiko
fujimori a hija del expresidente
encarcelado Alberto fujimori y que
genera un enorme rechazo entre la mitad
del país sea como sea desde el principio
pareció Claro que pese a sus grandes
promesas Castillo lo iba a tener muy
pero que muy complicado es un presidente
que asumió el cargo con un nivel muy
bajo de apoyo no tenía un partido
político le costó mucho armar un
gabinete el gabinete ha cambiado
constantemente y ha habido una constante
lucha de poder con el congreso Flavia
freidenberg politóloga de la Universidad
Nacional Autónoma de México sin
experiencia política sin un proyecto
claro y con un rezazo frontal del
parlamento los poco más de 16 meses que
el castillo estuvo al frente del país
fueron un auténtico desastre en apenas
95 días este presidente tuvo cinco
gobiernos y 78 ministros distintos
prácticamente los nombramientos se
sucedían cada semana solamente una
persona Roberto Sánchez ministro de
comercio exterior y turismo logró
permanecer en el cargo durante todo ese
tiempo otro serán cesados o dimitían
entre escándalos y desencuentros de todo
tipo algunas carteras tan importantes en
la política peruana como la del
Ministerio del interior o la del
Ministerio de agricultura han visto
pasar a siete y seis ministros
respectivamente insisto en menos de un
año y medio una auténtica locura Pedro
castillo cambiaba de gobierno más veces
que de calcetines
[Música]
evidentemente con tanta ira y venida
cualquier acción de gobierno en la
práctica era imposible y eso no es todo
a semejante vaivén tenemos que sumar un
congreso que decidió hacerle la vida
imposible la propia incompetencia y la
ausencia de proyectos de un presidente
que fue alternando entre apoyos
marxistas y conservadores y por si no
fuera suficiente un montón de
investigaciones por corrupción que le
llegaban hasta el cuello y de hecho en
octubre del 2022 os encontramos con esta
noticia atento 12 de octubre de 2022 la
Fiscalía de Perú denuncia al presidente
Pedro castillo y lo acusa de liderar una
organización criminal la fiscal sostiene
que la trama está enquistada en el
Palacio de Gobierno con la finalidad de
copar controlar y direccionar procesos
de contrataciones para obtener ganancias
ilícitas en total Castillo su mujer su
cuñada y dos sobrinos se enfrentaban en
total a seis investigaciones distintas
sobre tráfico de influencias
contrataciones irregulares sobornos
incluso plagios entre otros posibles
delitos en resumen la etapa de Pedro
Castillo como presidente ha sido una
larga tortura tanto para el mismo como
para el conjunto del país hablamos de
cerca de 200 escándalos políticos de
todo tipo en menos de 500 días y así
queridos amigos amigas es como llegamos
al 7 de diciembre del 2022 el día en el
que Castillo hizo saltar por los aires
su presidencia ahora bien Por qué lo
hizo En qué consistió exactamente el
calificado como golpe de estado
estuvimos realmente como tantos han
sugerido ante el intento de llevar a
cabo una nueva Revolución socialista en
América Latina Por qué fracasó este acto
de subversión institucional Pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
el no golpe de estado
en apenas 16 meses el congreso del Perú
llevó a cabo tres procesos de vacancia
presidencial contra Pedro Castillo
la vacancia presidencial es algo así
como una moción de censura es el
mecanismo que la Constitución peruana le
reconoce el congreso para deponer a un
presidente por varias razones entre
ellas la incapacidad moral lo que por
supuesto puede significar prácticamente
cualquier cosa es decir el parlamento
tiene vía libre para perseguir a los
presidentes en una interminable sucesión
de emociones de censura
llevamos más de 16 meses
de continua y observada campaña de
ataque sin cuartel a la institución
presidencial
situación nunca antes vista en la
historia peruana Pues bien El caso es
que los dos primeros intentos fracasaron
y el tercer intento que tenía que
votarse el miércoles 7 de diciembre iba
por el mismo camino sin embargo ese
mismo miércoles a primera hora de la
mañana ocurrió algo
[Música]
el ex jefe de gabinete del Ministerio de
vivienda salatiel marrufo testificó ante
una comisión de investigación del
Congreso declaro que tanto el entonces
ministro de vivienda heiner Alvarado
como él mismo hacían pagos recurrentes
tanto a Castillo como a la hermana de
este a cambio de mantener sus puestos el
dinero supuestamente procedía de Sada
goray una empresaria del sector
inmobiliario y tenía como destino sobre
todo el pago de sobornos y campañas en
favor del presidente ya sabéis
Ministerio de la vivienda empresaria del
sector inmobiliario las piezas parecen
encajar sea uno cierta esta declaración
El caso es que a partir de ahí los
acontecimientos se sucedieron será que
quizás temieron que esta declaración
terminara por sumar en el congreso los
votos suficientes para aprobarse la
propuesta de vacancia no lo sabemos pero
a las 16:46 la primera ministra de
Castillo Betsy Chávez hizo una
convocatoria urgente a través del grupo
de WhatsApp que tenía los miembros del
gobierno para que los ministros se
personaran lo antes posible porque este
sería un día histórico vaya si lo fue
poco después un tembloroso castillo
compareció en televisión para anunciar
este bombazo político
[Música]
tomamos la decisión de establecer Un
gobierno de excepción orientado a
restablecer el estado de derecho y la
democracia a cuyo efecto se dictan las
siguientes medidas disolver
temporalmente El Congreso de la
República e instaurar Un gobierno de
emergencia excepcional convocar en el
más breve plazo a elecciones para un
nuevo congreso con facultades
constituyentes para elaborar una nueva
constitución en un plazo no mayor de
nueve meses a partir de la fecha y hasta
que se instaure el nuevo el nuevo
congreso de la república se gobernará
mediante decretos ley
sin capacidad constitucional alguna para
hacerlo Castillo anunció la disolución
del Congreso la instauración de un
gobierno de excepción un toque de queda
y la organización de la justicia fue lo
que muchos calificaron incluido el
propio tribunal constitucional del país
como un intento de golpe de estado
[Música]
lo que nosotros hemos señalado en primer
lugar es que se ha producido un golpe de
estado el señor Pedro Castillo está al
margen de la Constitución y la ley Nadie
debe
obediencia a un gobierno usurpador ojo y
esto es importante matizarlo A
diferencia de lo que se ha dicho por ahí
la acción de Castillo no tenía nada que
ver con ninguna especie de revolución
socialista sino que su objetivo era
mantenerse en el poder escapar de las
acusaciones de la fiscalía y dejar atrás
el bloqueo del Congreso no tenía ningún
fundamento constitucional para lo que
hizo se enteró de que en el congreso ya
tenían 87 votos para vacarlo y creyó
erróneamente que la población las
fuerzas armadas y la Policía Nacional lo
iban a respaldar Y eso no fue así
Gustavo adrianzen exministro de Justicia
El caso es que al terminar su discurso
tanto la primera ministra como otros
nueve miembros del gabinete anunciaron
su dimisión por su parte las principales
instituciones del país esto es el
Congreso el ejército la policía y el
poder judicial dejaron Claro que no
acatarían bajo ningún concepto el plan
del presidente
de esa forma apenas una hora después de
proclamar el cierre del Congreso
Castillo abandonó con su familia y con
su abogado y ex Primer Ministro Aníbal
Torres el Palacio presidencial a las
1:40 menos de dos horas después de dar
su discurso de forma simultánea el
congreso lo destituía al tiempo que el
presidente estaba ya formalmente
detenido Castillo intentó llegar a la
embajada de México pero no lo consiguió
sus propios escoltas por orden directa
de la cúpula policial pararon la
camioneta donde se trasladaba el
presidente y procedieron a su detención
pero llegamos hasta aquí la pregunta es
por qué fracasó esta subversión porque
apenas duró lo mismo que un par de
episodios de Lala oeste pues lo cierto
Es que la estrategia del presidente del
Perú fue tan incompetente como lo fue su
gobierno Nada nuevo bajo el sol
no había plan no había justificación no
tenía apoyos y ni siquiera la mayoría de
sus ministros lo conocían no se había
preparado absolutamente nada tal y como
ha confirmado el jefe del Comando
conjunto de las fuerzas armadas el
general Manuel Gómez de la Torre el
expresidente nunca les pidió su apoyo
Castillo estaba Prácticamente solo y por
fortuna ni siquiera intentó que fuera
diferente era un hombre absolutamente
superado por los acontecimientos vamos
que más que de golpe de estado casi que
podemos hablar de disparate improvisado
por supuesto a nivel internacional
ocurrió tres cuartas partes de lo mismo
tal vez con Prácticamente la única
excepción de Andrés Manuel López Obrador
y Luis Arce consideramos lamentable que
por los intereses de las élites
económicas y políticas desde el comienzo
de la presidencia legítima de Pedro
Castillo se haya mantenido un ambiente
de confrontación y hostilidad en su
contra hasta llevarlo a tomar decisiones
que le han servido sus adversarios para
consumar su destitución con el sui
generis precepto de incapacidad moral
Andrés Manuel López Obrador desde un
inicio a la derecha peruana intentó
derrocar a un gobierno democráticamente
electo por el pueblo por las clases
Humildes que buscan más inclusión y
Justicia social Luis Arce presidente de
Bolivia ahora viene un momento porque
este no es el final de la historia
Castillo es culpable pero no es el único
culpable el problema de Perú va mucho
más allá del ya ex presidente atentos
[Música]
el Titanic político del Perú
Después de tres procesos de vacancia en
apenas 16 meses y mientras Pedro
Castillo será procesado por rebelión y
quizás también por conspiración El Perú
tiene una nueva presidenta Dina boluarte
la vicepresidenta de Castillo dimitió
otras el intento golpista y fue muy
clara al condenar a su anterior socio
político Se ha producido un intento de
golpe de estado una impronta promovida
por el señor Pedro Castillo que no ha
encontrado eco las instituciones de la
democracia y en la calle este congreso
de la República atendiendo al mandato
constitucional ha tomado una decisión y
es mi deber actuar en consecuencia Dina
boluarte vicepresidenta de Pedro
castillo y nueva presidenta del Perú la
nueva presidenta le ha pedido al
parlamento una tregua política y ha
prometido Establecer un gobierno de
unidad nacional donde estén
representadas todas las fuerzas
políticas algo que Aparentemente ha sido
bien recibido por los grupos políticos
no es momento de ideologías ni de
derechas o de izquierdas presidenta
boluarte le deseamos éxitos en la
conformación de un gobierno de unidad
nacional keiko sin embargo qué queréis
que os diga es casi seguro que la nueva
presidenta volverá a tener prácticamente
los mismos problemas que tuvo Castillo
incluida una investigación por blanqueo
de capitales incluso puede que sus
problemas terminen siendo peores porque
su perfil es mucho más ideológico está
mucho más escorado a la extrema
izquierda
[Música]
pero es que además el problema del Perú
no era exclusivamente Castillo sino
sobre todo la persistente catástrofe
política que atraviesa el país boluarte
es la sexta presidenta y el país ha
tenido en los últimos cinco años El
Congreso prácticamente se ha negado a
trabajar lealmente con todos los últimos
presidentes del país y ojo porque si
algo está haciendo el congreso es
acaparar cada vez más y más poder hasta
el punto de que El Ejecutivo se está
convirtiendo en un actor irrelevante
prácticamente en el muñeco del pim Pam
Pum de hecho en toda esta crisis
política ha tenido mucho que ver una ley
que se aprobó estamos hablando por
supuesto de la ley 31 355 una ley que de
facto rompe el equilibrio de poderes
entre el gobierno y el congreso me
explico en Perú El Congreso tiene la
capacidad de destituir al presidente al
mismo tiempo el gobierno tiene la
capacidad de disolver al congreso y
convocar a elecciones legislativas si la
cámara le niega al gobierno
de confianza
sin embargo desde la aprobación de la
ley 31 355 en la práctica esta potestad
ha desaparecido y claro Esto hace que si
el Gobierno no tiene una mayoría
parlamentaria tal y como suele ocurrir
en Perú donde el parlamento está casi
siempre muy fragmentado Entonces el
gobierno está completamente vendido no
puede aprobar nada y no puede presionar
a los legisladores
porque el congreso actual ha roto el
equilibrio de poderes porque ha hecho
una interpretación a su manera en la
Constitución y sin cambiar la
Constitución con una ley en la
interpretado
lo primero que hay que entender es que
la cuestión de confianza facultativa a
la que pide el gobierno se ha reducido
enormemente en la práctica del
presidente jamás podría disolver el
congreso ananeira abogada y profesora de
derecho constitucional en la universidad
del Pacífico y sabéis que esta ruptura
del equilibrio de poderes tiene
precisamente mucho que ver con el
desastre que ha sido el Gobierno de
Castillo el congreso ha podido hacerle
la vida imposible al gobierno sin tener
la más mínima consecuencia es decir
pesos han desaparecido
[Música]
esto por ejemplo ha hecho que el
congreso haya marginado casi 70
proyectos de ley enviados por el
gobierno y quizás por eso el nivel de
desaprobación del Congreso es de casi el
90%, todo un récord
y la verdad no augura Nada nuevo para
los siguientes gobiernos pero ojo que no
se trata solo de una cuestión
estrictamente política o electoral
prácticamente todos los antecesores de
Pedro Castillo desde la época de
fujimori han sido procesados por
corrupción echamos un vistazo pues
fijaos
fujimori está en la cárcel por
corrupción y por crímenes de lesa
humanidad Alan García acabó con su vida
en 2019 cuando estaba siendo detenido
tras el escándalo de odebrecht Alejandro
Toledo está en busca y captura y está
refugiado en Estados Unidos mientras
afronta una petición de extradición hoy
en taumala está siendo procesado
cuchinski tres cuartas partes de lo
mismo y ahora Castillo además de las
investigaciones por corrupción se
enfrenta también al posible delito de
rebelión y ojo que le pueden caer muchos
años de cárcel en general es todo un
auténtico desastre la política en Perú
cada vez es más inestable y está más
radicalizada y evidentemente eso tiene
consecuencias es obvio que la
estabilidad política afecta a la
confianza por parte de los inversores
les hace dudar si no hay confianza o
estas has acabado entonces obviamente la
tasa de inversión No va a progresar kur
burneo exministro de finanzas del Perú
de momento la expectativa de crecimiento
para el 2023 se está reduciendo a
entorno del 2 ciento y agencias
calificadoras como fits han revisado
recientemente las perspectivas del país
de estables a negativas los tiempos en
los que Perú fue la locomotora de
América Latina y una firme candidata a
convertirse en toda una potencia
regional parece En formar ya parte del
pasado os dejo la descripción un vídeo
donde os Contamos con todo detalle Por
qué cada vez Perú Está peor pero ahora
es tu turno es turno para ti qué crees
que ocurrirá con el nuevo gobierno del
Perú como valoras el paso de Castillo
por la presidencia qué piensas que tiene
que cambiar en este país para que vuelva
a convertirse en la locomotora de
América Latina déjanos tus respuestas
abajo en los comentarios y ahora si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante No
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte a visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]